AI can now predict heart attacks five
years in advance researchers at Oxford
have made a significant breakthrough
using artificial intelligence and Heart
Care they have developed a unique
biomarker called the fat radiomic
profile or FRP capable of identifying
people at high risk of a fatal heart
attack as much as 5 years in advance
typically patients with chest pain
receive a coronary City angiogram to
detect blockages in the vessels
supplying blood to the heart walls
despite normal scans some still face
future heart attacks due to signs not
immediately visible with conventional
diagnostic methods this is where this
new AI technology comes into play
instead of just looking for big
blockages FRP searches for tiny changes
around the heart's blood vessels like
inflammation or scarring using machine
learning the researchers developed the
FRP fingerprint that captures the level
of risk of a fatal heart attack they
tested the performance of FRP in 1500
people which showed that FRP had a
striking value in predicting heart
attacks which outperformed all current
clinical predictive tools